c'est un extrait du spectacle change
tout c'est une petite chanson que j'ai
préparé pour vous allez enfin savoir ce
gentil oulala je ne sais pas très
rassurée en découdre lors alone
vous êtes une radio génial vos émissions
tout pour plaire quand je vous écoute je
me régale vos animateurs sens super vous
avez je suis humoriste et je cherchais
une passe en radio pour me faire
connaître du public remplir les théâtres
les plus gros aux audiences sont
exceptionnels un vrai symbole de qualité
alors je vous lance un appel si jamais
vous m'entendez aux france inter
chez moi bosser chez vous ce serait
super
repeint c'est trop tôt pour moi
je suis pas humoriste en fin de carrière
j'accepterai même radio larzac skyrock
ou radio vinci pas
mais sortez moi de là je vous en prie
j'peux pas piffer se conduisit
[Musique]
toujours sur non plus à quelle belle
chanson on arrive à les y continuer en
arrivant ce matin déjà christine berrou
mady par toi et qu'on reçoit une meuf en
studio bennage et c'est de cela fait
chaud mais magma 10 et chroniqueur ils
sont vraiment ou sachiez je les
programmes pour que les auditeurs
préfère me voir moi en tournée et elle
m'a dit le titre au moins gelé bien
choisis je dois reconnaître parce que
c'est vrai que ça fait du bien [ __ ]
surtout quand ça s'arrête
rtl sortie mois et iseult
non je dois les auditeurs j'avoue
que je pensais pas que ce serait
possible mais qui sont encore plus vieux
que j'ai cinquante fois le nom de la
radio écrit sur les murs en couleurs
on croirait que c'est pour
adecco
mais tout le public à alzheimer
je t'aime je suis là je europe c'est les
seuls clients appelé plan b d'une de
leurs émissions
au moins ils savent que c'est la chaîne
qu'on met
quand ton cas pas les autres stations
avant